new this afternoon cuts to our water  supply from lake mead and the colorado  river for the second straight year a  federal water shortage has been declared  federal water managers made that  announcement this morning lake mead and  lake powell right now are only about 28  percent full this means the amount of  water nevada arizona california and  mexico can use from the river is going  to be cut nevada already uses less water  than this new amount however arizona has  to cut its use by 21 percent the  interior department says more cuts are  on the way  to date  the states collectively have not  identified  and adopted specific actions of  sufficient magnitude that would  stabilize the system  the federal government is going to cut  water usage by an additional 15 to 30  percent across all states on the  colorado river